The ListView starts by requesting a view
for every visible item,
however many you can fit onto the screen.
It'll also create a couple in either
direction to make sure we can scroll
without seeing a flicker
as a new view is created and populated.
Then it creates new items just in time.
So it's next in line
to be visible to the user.
So if the user never scrolls
to the bottom of the list,
the ListView will never request
that view from the adapter.
But this is really just a half measure.
As you can see,
if the user keeps scrolling,
we could potentially
just keep adding new views,
even if they disappear
off the top of the screen.
Eventually that's going to lead
to the same impact in memory use
and performance as if we had
just created all of these views
directly at the beginning.
The solution is recycling each view
as it scrolls off the screen,
allowing it to be reused
when we need to show another item
as it moves into view at the top or bottom.
So rather than having to create
and then hold in memory
each item of the list
as it comes into view,
we only need to do the creation step
for the number of visible items
and a couple on either side.
Then, whenever a new list item
comes into view,
we just update the data displayed
in one of our items in our recycle bin.
The result?
Less memory overhead, smoother scrolling
and less view management
you have to do yourself.
This same recycling behavior is implemented
across all AdapterView descended classes,
such as GridView and ListView,
which also introduces the reason
that the adapter isn't built
directly into these controls themself.
By keeping them separate,
your adapter defines how to display
each element of the underlying data,
while the adapter view
implementation itself
is responsible for controlling
how each of these elements is laid out.
Be it a list or a grid
in these particular instances.